everyone this is kevin from the chess
website calm and today we are in Game
eleven of the 2016 World Chess
Championship game number Tim was pretty
intense magnus carlsen finally getting
that first Viktor he's been looking for
in the tournaments tying things up going
into game number eleven now both sides
only have white one more time cardiac
ain't gonna be playing the white pieces
today in the game number eleven then we
take a day off and then Carlson comes
back in him game twelve on November 28th
it's gonna be playing the white pieces
so expecting big things from carjacking
he almost felt the victory in his hands
knowing that three games away from from
being the champion did give up at that
window Magnus Carlsen last game this is
last shot though to really do something
big so I'm expecting big things from
karyakin if he doesn't want to be
champion decided to start out with pawn
to e4 been seeing this throughout the
tournament pawn to e5 Knight f3 knight
c6 Bishop b5 up on to a6 Bishop back
here to a4 so very similar to what we
saw in Game two now if you remember Game
two it was one of the shortest and it
was pretty uneventful karyakin played
the white pieces in that game as well
guess on the King side Bishop here to e7
upon to d3 all of these moves are the
exact same kind of odd I think to be
playing this Magnus Carlsen defended it
extremely well in Game two and he's just
playing the same moves they'd aren't
taking very long for this opening so far
pawn to d6 solidifying that pawn chain
pawn to a3 castle on the King side for
black at Knight to c3 and then the first
change in variation actually comes from
Magnus crossing cardiac and is played
identically to a game number two but
Magnus Carlsen decides to go ahead and
play Bishop to e6 if you remember from
game number two it was kind of a couple
ways to attack this Bishop here on b3
you can play Knight to a5 which is what
he played in game number two or he could
play Bishop here to e6 Bishop to e6 is
more of a let's just trade off all
material on board Knight to a5 in my
opinion is more of okay I'm gonna keep
my options open I still want to start to
attack you and that's kind of what we
saw in game 2 but then we seen that up
here to d5 Knight down here at the d4 so
somewhat copying the Moose both sides
have an outpost with their Knights in
the center of the board
but this opens up the door for just mass
exchange on board so they take some f6
Bishop here f6 Bishop takes pawn
recaptures and then pawn up here to f4
magnus carlsen is completely fine to
exchange all material if he could just
draw right now you have to get to move
30 in this particular tournament he
would getting into game number 12 with
the white pieces he kind of has the
momentum on his hit and aside because he
does have that that latest victory he
played extremely well so although with
the opening so far very odd to see
Kuryakin come out with in my opinion a
somewhat Bell opening that we we've seen
not too long ago and knowing that Magnus
Carlsen is extremely prepared for this
opening Carlsen responds with pawn to c5
says okay if you're gonna attack on the
king saud I'll go and tack on the Queen
side Queen here to g4 getting ready to
push forward with pawn to f5 trying to
break up this King side of the board as
much as possible Queen out here to d7
just to protect these light squares as
much as possible pawn up here to f5 does
not want to capture yet decides first to
go and bring his work over here to e8
just loading up the box here trying to
hold down the square here on e6 a Bishop
e2 d2 he had a few options as far as
where he could have gone instead of
Bishop to d2 I probably just would've
played Bishop to h6 the pawn can't move
because it's being pinned down from this
Queen right here I think he adds a lot
of pressure on his opponent could have
even just been aggressive with Bishop to
f4 really starts to attack a lot of the
center of the board played in my opinion
more of the the passive wait and see
Bishop to d2 cross and pawn to c4 upon
here to h3 and then Carson just kind of
pushing expanding space doing a good job
of playing defensive but improving his
position on the board pawn takes on c3
and then pawn to d5 he knows that he
doesn't have to take material back right
away because his opponent can't take
here on d4 because then Bishop to d4
this is forking the rook here on a1
after check so we're not going to see
that capture so he kind of has an
in-between move a pawn here to the e5
and then after Bishop to g5 Carlson's
hey that's great I'll exchange the
bishops off the board and then pawn to
e4 after the pond east six both sides
completely content with just exchange of
material off the board Queen here to e6
and after the pawn takes Carson says I'm
gonna give you that pawn and material
advantage because I have a passed pawn
here on e3 and I'm gonna be looking to
push that and you're just gonna have to
use all your material to kind of hold on
to that square right there so I work
here too II won upon here to h6 forcing
the Queen to move Queen here to h5 and
then pushing it to e2
now if we can't look at cart yakin has
more pawns on board and actually has to
pass pawns
a really good setup the only problem is
he's never gonna be able to push these
ponds because Magnus Carlsen is putting
too much pressure the pawn here on e 2
essentially means that this rook can't
really move on board the Queen can't
really defend both of these ponds due to
centralise this black Queen right here
and then just dance around with your
rook there's no way for Kuryakin to much
on here he just gave up all his material
completely okay with Carlsen Queen over
here to f3 pawn to e5 starting to push a
little bit on the Queen side pawn to c3
Queen down here to a2 Queen C 6 and then
rook to e6 attacking the Queen and as
far as where the Queen could go to
decides to go in and play Queen here to
see a probably a little bit worse if he
did take the material so let's say Queen
takes on b5 but then it gets tricky with
Queen over here to d2 attacking the rook
essentially the Queen has to come down
here to be 1 but then after the Queen
takes on c3 getting ready to take this
pawn here on c4 I don't think Magnus
Carlsen could potentially win in this
position but it's just it gives away all
the advantage that karyakin possibly has
in the game so a queen up here to c8
King to h7 pawn to c4 Queen over here to
d2 threatening that rook decides okay
let's go and exchange rooks on board
after Queen to e1 check King here to h2
and then we just see after Queen to e4
there is a draw in the game so 34 moves
that kind of scene
they were just trying to get to move 30
there's no way to kind of stop this you
know the white can't let the pawn come
down here to eat one I get that Queen so
essentially he's just gonna be checking
perpetually over and over so at the end
of the day we have a very very
uneventful game number 11 a little
disappointed that Kuryakin didn't go for
the win with some much different opening
theory but although we do have a draw
which makes game 12 pretty exciting
Magnus Carlsen has got to be feeling
pretty good he has the white pieces with
things tied up so it's in his court now
I don't think he wants to go to a
tiebreaker where they start to get into
some some blitz rapid chess style you
know there's just too much variance and
that could easily make a blunder and
then lose the World Championship not how
you want to go about it even though he
is a very very talented fast chess
player so although expecting big things
in two days from Magnus Carlsen I do not
expect him to come out and play an
opening like we did see from Kuryakin
game number 11 so thank you guys for
watching
definitely a short video but it was a
short game so I'll see you guys in the
next one
take care